مع كل اطلاق على طول الجبهات في اوكرانيا
يكسب اخر على الطرف المقابل من الكره
الارضيه فالحرب الدائره منذ عام وبغض
النظر عن مضاعفاتها ضاعفت مقاوليها
والمتكسبين منها في الولايات المتحده خلقت
الحرب الاوكرانيه جماعات ضغط لدعم البلد
المنكوب مجانا ما لبث ان تكشف حجم المكاسب
الماليه التي تجنيها من تجاره الاسلحه بين
الداعمين والمحاربين وفقا لبيانات قانون
فاره الذي يراقب ممثلي جماعه الضغط لصالح
جهات غير امريكيه فان عدد هؤلاء تضاعف
مؤخرا من 11 ممثلا في بدايه حرب اوكرانيا
الى 25 ممثلا خلال عام تعد شركه بي جي ار
ابرز شركات الضغط العامله من اجل اوكرانيا
دفعت عام 2022 نصف مليون دولار لمقاول
البانتاجون شركه ريثيون شركه بي جي ار
حصلت على اكثر من مليار دولار من العقود
الامريكيه المتعلقه بحرب اوكرانيا اضافه
لشركات مثل ميركوري
تقول المعلومات ان الانفاق الدفاعيه
الاميركيه يستمر بالتضخم اذ يقدر ما تلقاه
مقاول والاسلحه والدفاع ما بين 500 مليون
دولار و 860 مليون دولار من ميزانيه
الدفاع للعام الحالي
ومع دخول الحرب في اوكرانيا عامها الثاني
يشكك الاعلام الامريكي في ان تتوقف فاتوره
المقاولين فاتوره كلما طالت طال امد
الحربي ومضاعفتها